в чаті чи нас чудно чи видно бо це
найголовніше чи є тут зв'язок
нормальний щоб ми розуміли для
себе Цей голос за кадром це я Марія
мадзігун всіх Вітаю Сьогодні ми
знаходимось біля державного бюро
розслідувань не як зазвичай тут
проходить виставка картинна галерея ви
будете вражені тому що ці картини просто
прекрасні навіяно навіяно отими подіями
біля музею ра і я впевнена що вам
сподобається а я для вас проведу
обов'язкову екскурсію цими картинами
розповім як там що з чого складається і
так далі
тому прошу пройти за мною моя
екскурсійна група до картин Ходімо не
загубіться я думаю що мене буде помітно
здалеку Дозвольте Дозвольте у нас
екскурсія перепрошую у нас
екскурсія говор
Отже перший
експонат Віктор
васніцов Я думаю що якби він здогадався
що взагалі таке теоретично може бути що
на музеї де зберігатиметься ця картина
буде напад він би намалював Це трошки
по-іншому але ми бачимо три Вершники три
Вершники у нас це Володимир Зеленський
пані Ірина бенедиктова дивіться як їй
пасує цей лук з якого стріляти хоча у
нас Зеленський майстер стрілянини з луку
тут якби От вже як подумати Можливо вони
просто обмінялись ролями тимчасово і хто
у нас третій хто у нас третій це ольоша
бабіков це Альоша бабіков дивіться який
краснь на білому коні все пасує у нього
навіть чоботи зелені бачите зверніть
увагу група зверніть увагу це важливі
деталі ось такий у нас перший експонат
холсто олія все як
треба
найцінніше найцінніший скарб цієї
виставки запитай ще раз чи видно чи чут
чи видно чи чутно чатик мовчить вітаю
друзі хтось написав хтось написав вітаю
друзі значить вони почули мене Я маю
надію
да Перевір будь ласка в Ютубі звук є чи
нема початик щось не пише Це європейська
солірні ми перевіряємо ще чи є звук тому
трошки призупинили все чути все дякую
написали далі далі так далі далілі такце
у на альша
бабіков Владимир голобородькович як
написав автор і Ірина
бенедиктова Марія дуже гарно
зашла
сбода дуже гарний Дуже гарна парасолька
коіного
кольорущо холоди
запеку та тому щось незрозуміло я буду
показувати текст і люди просто прочитати
Ну я пропоную піти далі я так в принципі
все
прокоментувала що у нас далі у нас далі
найцінніший експонат цієї виставки це
Володя Зеленський який у нас він сказав
совсм поехали фотографія але це не точно
орбітальний ульт фантазії білий
невідомий порошок ймовірно Космічний пил
друзі Космічний пил на фоні можете
побачити
і такий прекрасний у нас Космічний
президент він просто космічно класнити
Це нам голушиться ще оця як вона
називається косовородка як вона
називається ну да це косовородка це
національний одяг от влучно підмітив
художник влучно помітив
автор А оце вона Да оце вона гуслярі
холсталія душевні
струниудож виін розумієте він побачив от
він в майбутнє дивився він вгледів Там
саме Ці
особистості неповторний
[музика]
оригінал Віктор васніцов Що ж я думаю що
як нам краще повернутись туди Так там ще
є одна картина цікава дуже пікантна
заберіть дітей від екранів дуже пікантна
картина Нічого там пікантного нема
це Мане є різниця між клодом Моне і
клодом Мане До речі Вони були
життізнайомі це реальний факт вони були
одного разу зустрілись на виставці тому
що їх картини переплутали вони
виставляли свої картини
і Ну де вони їх виставляли там
переплутали назви і вони якби Таким
чином познайомились їхня зустріч
відбулася з конфлікту але потім вони
стали хорошими друзями Отже це у нас
Мане сніданок на траві А в чому різниця
між Моне і
Мане дивіться Клод Моне - це схід сонця
враження є така дуже відома картина там
у нього більш все
таке Ну в яскравих загугліть просто вам
буде простіше загуглити враження схід
сонця Клод Моне через о і ви побачите
якби що Мане він малював людей а Клод
Моне він малював от там пейзажі природу
і таке інше це наскільки я от знайома з
його творчістю А хто малював венедиктову
малював венедиктову мабуть Мане дуже
надихнувся І от вирішив він надихнувся
ось цією роботою Яна верера зараз оце
треба написати позати
людям Якщо я порушу закон то піду сказав
одного разу Зеленський і порушив і пішов
в парк щой зображено на картині
геніального
художника Ян вермеєр бабікови з перловим
кульчиком це у нас пан бабіков я його
переплутала з
венедиктовою не дивно тому що
венедиктова ось дивиться прекрасне це
саме цією картиною мабуть надихнулись
аце треба запитати глядачів що це за
картина може це вони вони не вгадають
тому що це Леонардо
зевінчі
зен загадкова Посмішка Мони венедиктовий
холстоліє велика кількість таємничості і
загадковості Та ви й самі бачите що тут
коментувати Мені дуже сподобалось Я б на
місці пані венедикто собі б таку картину
завела бо вона Дивіться яка тут ну
просто
красуня трошки здивована правда але то
не зле Зате брови на місці відмінність
від
Леонардо да Вінчі в тому що у монелізи
немає брів я зараз не жартую в неї
серйозно немає брів самі перевірте А у
пані бенедиктової брови
є вона посміхається немає нічого
загадкового в її посмішки Вона просто
посміхається типу г
Федір решетніков Знову двійка холст олія
факапи пише автор у нас тут двійку
отримав Олександр бабіков він повернувся
додому його зустрічає зі школи песик а
мати дивиться на нього і думає Господи
прости Нащо мені така Кара Подивіться на
її погляд і ви в її очах все
[музика]
побачите ві із роботи в дбр Він приніс
не двійку а чергову справу з дбр і мати
не може зрозуміти що це таке він
наколіпав там Отже проходимо далі тут
цікаво тут сучасне мистецтво теж я таке
дуже люблю це знову Сальвадор Далі у нас
друзі Сальвадор Далі м'яка конструкція
із вареними бобами називається картина
холсто олія галюцинації ЛСД РСР
псілобіцин
деметлтриптамін картини сюрреаліста
Сальвадора далі сповнені загадок
відкритів для інтерпретацій тому Ось
така інтерпретація є доречної зелені
[музика]
боби тут немає опису але в принципі Ну
на шварснегіра
схожий відкриває відкроковує
шампанське хоро дівчата можуть взяти
собі на замітку Можливо десь повісити
собі в спальню можна над
ліжком
красавчи красавчик каже Луганський
луганському теж
сподобалось Так тут у нас бачите трошки
зацензурена картина теж Ми все
передбачили щоб діти могли спокійно
переглядати все це ось зацензурили
Мікеланджело створення
двр така версія цієї картини
загальновідомої є дуже багато зображень
картина одночасно загадкова і проста
Вона називається створення дбр але
зображує чомусь створення президента
[музика]
Зеленського міфічним персонажем до
ранкува
[музика]
сгодніні дуже гарний
Вернісаж все в Зака
за зараз буде брифінг депутатівми поки
що перер екскурсію але обов'язково
повернемось тому що там ще є багато
картин
де де депутати куди всроділися
оп куди всі поділися всі пішликлала свою
парасольку перерва перерва в екскурсію
невеличка перерва пишіть що пишіть Що Що
сходити зробити собі чаю там сподобалось
Запишіть будь ласка що сподобалось
напишіть на екскурсіях перерва це
нормально їду теж треба трошки
відпочити
що вам хочу сказати я то взагалі не дуже
люблю картини і живопис ну це не моє я
вже про це багато разів казав Але
сучасне мистецтво сучасне ось таке в
такому вигляді Мені подобається це
прикольно от от фотожаби сучасне
мистецтво це прикольно Це просто
насамперед це прикольно це не то що ти
побачив картину такий а Боже яка картина
ну це отце прикольно це такий знаєте як
журавель писав додай драйву да це такий
трошки є рок-н-ролу в цих картинах бо ну
зрозуміло що давінші там лотні пензля
невідомого генія із фотореалістичною
точністю наче у дзеркалі Зеленський
зображений мужнім сильним високим
справжнім світовим лідером сьогодні
виставка картин вона є дуже популярна
багато фотографів багато людей які
просто дивляться людей яківіть не можемо
підійти якщо
диви ще раз це державна
бюророзслідуваньня філія телеканалу 1+1
пише автор яка раніше називалась
міністерством культури найближчим часом
оголосить Цей вид живопису національним
спадком який нація усім кварталом буде
зберігати розвивати і
[музика]
популяризувати оце українська Готика
українська Готика
так альтернативна реальність та
натхнення Ця картина пензлі американц
Гранта вуда потрапила до нас із
паралельної реальності там Ірина
венедиктова подалася до США Я зрозумів
Ну що не починається ми шмо прямий ефір
журналісти дуже ревнують До прямих
ефірів я їх
розумію Даня і єронімус босг пекло
[музика]
теж такі тут персонажі цікаві і Як
бачите десь там знизу затисалась Ірина
венедиктова Вона проходила повс її
випадково там
сфотографували державне бюро
переслідувань треба вішити вже нову
табли навіть проблеми з зі звуко щось
тут
вни для своїх кримінальних справ
політичні репресії в Україні
Зеленський себе перейменовувати
Володимира ростовича бо він на цей шлях
став твердо і по цьому шляху рухається
ми неспроможності не тільки
керувати не тільки виконувати свої
обіцянки вони
згадуютьлі абсолютно порожні приводи для
того щоб заважати працювати народним
депутатам для того щоб заважати
працювати Порошенку який фактично
замість влади проводить міжнародні
зустрічі домовляється про підтримку
України про допомогу надання Україні
замість цьгощо Ми ходили
по хочу створювати картим приз мы под
дбр у нас очередное шоу от дбр сначала
они ворвались без
решение суда читаете незаконно в здание
музея со
спецназом с оружием всё как положено
теперь они устраивают очередного шоу
Скажем так с приводом Петра Порошенко на
допрос по картинам уже оказывается
картины были как-то незаконно ввезены в
страну потом правда поменялась риторика
что были вывезены потом вс-таки опять
ввезены в общем такого рода качели И вы
видели
Прекрасную коллекцию новых картин Я
думаю что они им будут полезны а картина
ответа на вопрос касаемо плёнок Ермака
плёнок трубы и так далее и так далее и
так далее для того чтобы народ отвлечь
от насущных проблем от того что
экономика летит в
тартороры проводятся Вот такие вот акции
чтобы Порошенко там привести на допыт и
так далее и так далее и так далее Завтра
я думаю что на принес ему выпишут новую
повестку в новом деле будет новое
уголовное дело почему так долго
затянулась весна и почему так быстро
пришло лето в принципе Почему бы и нет
это тоже можно имплементировать как
уголовное преследование уголовное дело
это на тоже виноват Порошенко
оставайтесь с нами следите за нашими
трансляциями Я думаю будет
интересно треба сказати про технічні
проблеми існують так
ч існують технічні проблеми з зв'язком
Ми не можемо на це ніяк Вплинути ми
стараємось щоби трансляція була але це
від нас не залежить навіть у телеканалів
деколи тормозить картинка тому що тут
перевантажений зараз зв'язок і нам
доводиться чекати коли він відновиться
Ми ні в якому разі не виключаємо зараз
трансляцію ми просто чекаємо коли
відновиться зв'язок якщо він зникає буду
мати надію що він не буде так більше
перериватись дуже сильно Андрій паробій
пішов тільки що е
Отакі справи друзі там зараз брифінг
депутатів тому я не можу продовжити
екскурсіюбуємо підійти до Кати можна
підійти до цих ближчих
Так це ми вже бачили її просто
перенесли Іван Шишкін такі мішки в
Радянському Союзі у багатьох весіли такі
копії картин але ц Ця картина унікальна
вона унікальна тому що там є всі
мешканці
лісу ранок у сосновому лісі якщо чесно
кажучи То навіщо отут от намалювали
Спецназ дбр бо вони себе вели як веіді
штовхалися
товкалися вони були дуже грубими і грубо
штовхали і били мене тримаю
тримаю
зараз
так Слава Україні геро
Слава шановні журналісти
новнікра Ось така картина ви
знаєте ситуація яка сьогоднівається в
країні вона є дуже
загроз бо на
жаль Влада не тільки є
непрофесійною вона ще нікого не
чує
попереджав Дивіться це у нас пєро та
арлекі холст фарби кляузи очерніння
світлого образу президента вуглемисажею
дивіться поскільки там всі збираються то
мабуть вже приїжджає Петро Порошенко Я
так розумію бо дивіться там такий двіж
підст будемо зараз чекати коли він
приїде Можливо навіть він зверне увагу
на цю виставку картин ми вам
обов'язковожемо всі
обов'язково
журналісти вже підходять а
значить будемо спостерігати друзі не
знаю просто чекаємо що тут
буде всі Тут збираються Я стану десь
десь
тут А ось машина під'їхала ой-ойой
починається штовханина я буду знімати
згори Так
[музика]
простіше а ось Петро Олексійович іде
штопхаються дуже то я так обережно себе
поводжу саме тому саме тому європейська
Солідар чітко і послідовно буде боротися
за україную буде робити все для то щоб в
Україні була незалежність ми зберегли
наш суверенітет і все зробимо для цього
Дякую
Порошенко
Порошенко поро дорогі друзі Дякую
дякуюзі друзі Сьогодні на вулиці
тлюри стінами дбр
відбувається справжній містецька
подія зустріч з
прикра а шанувальники містецтва у нас
сидять зараз в
б і ми робимо все можливе для того щоби
оскільки вони заблокували можливість
киянам
здивитися
видатні картини митців які пов'язані з
Україною я гублюся в догад А навіщо я їм
сьогодні тут
знадобивться можу лише
передбачити що Вони хотять
вибачитися за брутальне порушення Закону
коли озброєний до зубів
Спецназ який оснащений набагато краще
ніж спецнас збройних сил
штурмував не Слов'янськ як шість років
тому а штурмував національний музей
ганчара ламаючи
двері роблячи без будь-якої санкції суду
порушення Конституції
України штурм національного
музею б'ючи журналістів перешкоджаючи їх
законній журналістській діяльності
ро атакуючи народних
депутатів переслідуючи
опозицію і тиснувши на дирекцію
національного
музею Можливо вони повідомлять що ті
злочинці які скоїли ці
злочи ті керівники які віддавали
незаконні накази і
замовники високих
кабінетів притягнуті до кримінальної
відповідальності звільнені з
роботи Як це має
відбуватися В правовій державі
рехуни намагалися
розповсюдити недостовірну інформацію про
те що
нібито ці твори мистецтво які нашими
зусиллями повернуті в Україну після
сторічної
відсутності нібито ввезені без митного
оформлення і з подивом коли вони
вламалися в музей коли вони викрали
документи побачили Митні
декларації потім вони сказали та чекайте
Та може цих коштів які перераховувались
з України податки незаплачені з подивом
побачили податкові декларації з повним
уплаченням податків до державного
бюджету України то може це були з
якихось інших рахунків та ні З власного
рахунку в українському банку і побачивши
всі платіжні
доручення і потім я твердо переконаний
що вони зараз мають сказати Вибачте
Петро Олексійович ми закриваємо цю
справу Ми приносимо вам вибачення і всі
хто причетний до ціє до цього злочину
будуть
наказані але в цьому театрі абсурду На
жаль цього не відбуло бу Хочу наголосити
що вони за цей рік дуже ретельно вивчили
кожну хвилину мого перебування на посаді
президента а я працював і до другої і до
третьої і до пятої ночі бо я не так
швидко втомлююсь як Володимир
Олександрович і в цих
умовах Я хочу окремо наголосити що після
того як не було знайдено абсолютно
нічого вони Пошли в події
пти семи 13 15тирічної довнини зараз я
не виключаю що вони уважно проаналізують
події 72 73 74го років коли я в
болградській середній школі номер 2
Одеській області отримував в першому
другому третьому і інших класах
похвальні листи як відмінник А ну
Порошенко завищувало оцінки і притягнути
до відповідальності треба його першу
вчитиль працюйте друзі насправді Влада
знаходиться насправді Влада знаходиться
в відчи безсиллі бо те що зараз робить
Влада нічого спільного
немає з європейськими цінностями з нашим
рухом в
Європу з нашими
досягненнями безвізовим режимом треть
річницю якого ми будемо святкувати
завтра бо Європейський союз це є
верховенство права а переслідування
опозиції подвійне
правосуддя Володимир Олександрович чим
це закінчується ви можете перепитати у
Віктора Федоровича Януковича
зателефонуйте йому він вам розкаже чим
він
закінчити Насправді я хочу подякувати
кожного хто сьогодні прийшов сюди на
вулицю сиімона птлюри Вони думають До
речі що вона знаходиться в Печерському
районі бо вони і Києва не знають і до
Києва не мають ніякого відношення і все
що вони будують будується на брехні але
брехня брехні дуже короткий номер брехня
Не перемагає правда Буде за нами
перемога Буде за нами наш рух в Європу
наш рух євро атлантичне співтовариство
буде продовжно І ми наша політична сила
буде працювати на Україну так як нашими
зусиллями сьогодні було прийнято рішення
про виділення Україні чергового траншу 2
млрд доларів До речі окремо заява була
керівництва міжнародних фінансових
організацій про блискучі реформи які
були проведені протягом останніх пти
років я які зробили міцною банківську
систему які укріпили економіку і яку
зараз
руйнує нова
недосвідчена Зелена Влада нових облич ще
раз наголошую керувати країною - це не
вести телевізійне шоу і наслідки
набагато важче Дуже дякую вам
спасибі
я кстати проверяла YouTube хорошо
идт ми продовжимо бо треба було
позахищати
дівчат в мене до тебе є
запитання Чому Тому чому чому Ну ти ж
представник
шаріять а відповідати на запитання не
хоче розумієте потримай будь ласка
позапитую тебе прямий ефір
хочу запитати в тебе знаєш
що кого
потеряв а хто А хто ще може
повідповідати замість
тебервськиххто все А в мене є дуже
багато запитань Слухайте я хотів
запитати про а
потримай я хотів запитати про
сьогоднішнє відео я хотів запитати про
що Толік мені завжди пише в Твіттері Я
перепрошую що він там хоче мене щось там
пообсикати я не знаю для чого я хочу от
представники шарія а вони всі морозяться
відповідати Нічого я не знаю чому якщо
мене щось питають Я завжди відповідаю а
їм так скажемо не в прямому ефірі скажу
що Ну трошки цикотнейм цьому тому що я
вважаю що вони не знають що відповідати
їм страшенько Я пропоную провести надалі
екскурсію подивитись що тут за картини
бо ми ще дуже багато картин не показали
давай
туіз проблем без проблем ви ж для людей
працюєте не хочете з людьми спілкуватись
люди пишуть що
є відповіді на елементарні прості
питання отак покивав отак от і все
ганьба якщо ганьба Плю там якщо вам було
що сказати ганьба ганьба давай
давай я вам скажу що як я луганчанин я
все життя прожив в Луганську до 14-го
року до війни і війна відбувається
по-перше інформаційно завдяки вам А я не
вам я глядачам розказую вони дивляться
нас пряні я до вас звертаюсь а глядачам
розказую що війна відбувається ще і
інформаційно і завдяки вам руський мир
так так званий руський мир приходить в
Луганськ і в Донецьк і в
Крим вам це подобається ну це не так це
приводить до смертей людей до загибелі
людей до війни до артилерії до
артилерійських пострілів в місті
розумієте і це насамперед завдяки вам
вашому
каналу сьогодні про ви розказуєте про
якісь лабораторії Сполучених Штатів в
Україні а потім люди кажуть Ой Та це ж
таке знаєте це треба Путіна позвать
Володя ві войска що ж это такое в
Україні коється бо ви маніпулюєте це
маніпуляції це відверто брехня і
маніпуляції Це правда що Зеленський вбив
свого брата голобородького
а це так Чи не
так А як вам картини Як вам картини Як
вам
картини Бачили там
рижатьфокс а нема що сказати
сказати
ганьба п
без
батьківщинизмен без нічого
ди ганьба плюсам ганьба плюсам ганьба
плюсам ганьба плюсам ганьба п ганьба п
Дякую за
увагу Дуже дякую ось таке
бачите га плюса ганьба плюса ганьба
плюса
ганьба ганьба маніпуляції і брехня
маніпуляції і брехня Оце це чому кричать
люди ганьба тому що маніпуляції і брехня
там знаходилось зараз багато камер
багато телеканалів немає зауважень до
телеканалів немає таких зауважень як до
телеканалу 1+1 розумієте Чому Тому що це
брехня і маніпуляції і брехня і
маніпуляції не просто просто так там в
угоду якомусь там з політиків або там
якомусь з Я не знаю там з бізнесменів це
маніпуляції вгоду Кремлю От і тому люди
і кричать ганьба і я я ну разом з людьми
я долучаюсь до цього ганьба плюсам
ганьба і на на запитання Чому багато
людей пишуть про канал 1+1 як канал г+г
відповіді в них нема На жаль от така от
справа бачите і немає що відповідати А я
пропоную все ж таки подивитись ще
картини бо це цікаво і прикольно Я зараз
віддам мікрофончик Марії мазгон Вона
візьме парасольку в
мене і ми спробуємо
провести
продовження екскурсії по намальованих
картинах
от як в таких умовах вести стріми
незрозуміло Ходімо
далі арлікіна я вам
[музика]
показувала Можливо так шаріївські
журналісти не будуть мене
штовхати Ліно вклоніння пастухів холст
олія соняшникова масло вершкове 72%
жирності продукти з додаванням масла без
гму У нас тут маленький маленький
Зеленський народився і
Діва Діва бенедиктова Його
народила
новонароджений Зеленський не розуміє а
прокурор венедиктова
дивиться на аграріїв суровим поглядом
нового домоуправління нашого
до до речі Ця картина дуже якісно
виконана ніби так і
треба
янван Ейк портрет подружня
подружжя баригоборців Боже Яка прекрасна
назва дивіться о цієї картини
цікава цікаві деталі є
по-перше по-перше тут є рекурсія
рекурсія - це явище коли ви наклад
ставити два дзеркала один напроти одного
і вони починають либ туди іти тобто
нібито їх сфотографували і там в
дзеркалі їхнє відображення зі спини це
по-перше по-друге тут є песя за песя
треба поставити лайк цьому каналу і
обов'язково підписатись бо песики дуже
милі по-третє Вона загубила черевичк Ось
він а ще дивіться ось черевички можна
дуже довго розглядати
справділабу червоні Так обов'язково
будуть виставлені вже запитували в
коментарях обов'язково виставимо ці
картини щоб ви їх могли розгледіти більш
крупно ви побачите їх в наших
соцмережах кого-то точно водил Серга тут
на выставку н кого-то точно водил Серга
на виставку
вангога це ерху яка
цеч інструмент Це яка це лютніст вже не
піаніст лютніст вже не
піаніст одна із ранніх картин
Караваджо вона існує в трьох версіях ця
унікальна таку ви ніде більше не
побачите
під цю Прекрасну мелодію проходимо далі
тут у нас сумна сумна іринушка треба ще
раз показати спецназівців Дор поки
музика така А Ходімо
зараз ось
[музика]
Я знайшов марш Зеленського марш
Зеленського пиши в
коментарях
Маш ну встигли встигли
показати іринушка Віктор васнецов хол
столия безнадги безнадьога дуже велика і
невтомна Ліза багуцкая Ні то не Ліза
багуцкая біля ставку в ахтирці
іринушка вона сумна сидить біля ставку і
дивиться на воду скільки туги самотності
і чисто
русской печалі було в її очах написав
автор Якщо продати всі ці картини і
пстити гроші на благодійність чи може
глядачі купили якусь одну з картину
це не до мене ці питання вирішите без
мене художник пров Борці з Порошенко на
привалі У мого дідуся з бабусею висіла
така теж копія картини завжди і я ніколи
в житті би не подумала що я таку картину
побачу в такій інтерпретації мабуть в
такій інтерпретації вона мені до вподоби
більше хол столі безсмислені кримінальні
справи жменька абсурду
хвалькуватість мисливець бабіков де їх в
Києві можна побачити де їх в Києві можна
побачити ми зараз знаходимось біля
державного бюро розслідувань це у нас
адресамона Петлюри 15 Ми ще тут будемо
можна під'їхати і
побачитит
про
так Сандро потячелі народження
політичних
переслідувань темпера на Холі
безпредел народження політичних
переслідуваньти італійського художника
тосканської школи Сандро Ботічеллі зараз
полотно
зберігається в галереї офіці Флоренція
Мені здається що їй пасує якраз брови
такі як треба
схвильовані цю картину ми вже частково
показували Пітер Брейгель старший притча
про
сліпих він передав бблій біблійний жет
сліпий веде незрячого і це якби така
отсилочка до того що ті хлопці були
трошки підсліпкуваті І наприклад побили
мене журналісти очевидно що вони були
сліпі в той момент що вони не зрозуміли
що я при виконанні своїх обов'язків що Я
веду зйомку і я журналістка мене не
можна бити вони мене побили були
сліпі поки ще одну картину ми пропустили
якраз музика підходить Зеленський на
коні
це ж плохой Хороший Злой как раз
Зеленський на коні під музику плохой
Хороший Злой Ілля рен в
туку на картині зображено
линного воїна його роль грає артист
зеленськи але не на роздоріжжі як того
передбачає традиційний сюжет а в
[оплески]
тупику
чуть-чуть Моріс ешер відносність
дбр заслідкуєте просто за сходинками
сходинки так це ті майже ті самі
сходинки які знаходяться на вході до
музею Гончара з іншого боку Куди вони
теж заходили вдирались до директора в
кабінет утримували його в кабінеті не
давали йому ні Подзвонити нічого не
зробити це саме по тих сходах вони
підіймались до нього в
[музика]
кабінет ви Спитаєте що це за
картина Вона просто ну на перший погляд
така дуже звичайна А ні друзі це казимір
Малевич тупий зелений
кут
холст фарби чистий геній безперечно
найбільш загадкова робота геніального
малеєвича Сергій Шнуров експонат
тональність с мінор натуральний із
крапленнями гармонічного
мінору та запозиченнями із паралельної
реальності
це в нього щось зелене тут росте на
столі якісь боби чи що це
таке
[музика]
це
босх його не важко впізнати босха дуже
легко впізнати так по сюжетах біблійних
несення
Христа фарби на дошці тяжка
доля Ісус який несе хрест І ті хто йому
допомагають це робити ті хто його туда
ведуть ті хто його туди ведуть так
Ми теж тут ведемо прямий ефір всі
знімають Карл брло в останній день барих
монументальне та епічне
полотно в нас тут зверху дивиться
Боженька Зеленський
хоча зважаючи на те що небо червоне хто
його знає хто він
Це ж майже як Помпеї
але дуже це як Помпей але Дуже схоже на
сьогодніш Карл брлов це Карл брлов
метафорично зобразив день інавгурації
президента коли за
народнимиметами в той же день є початок
епохи кінця зобожіння а також знаменує
собою початок весни Коли вона прийшла і
ось-ось когось почнуть
саджати
от це ми бачили Це ми бачили Ми ще з
того боку не були там ми все вже поба
бачили з вами хто не бачивчайте мотайте
на початок ст сподобалось Найбільше я її
не бачила Боже
це от якщо чесно кажучи я б її купив би
собі
от може ми якось домовимося з інчі
Зеленський з
горностаєм дерево
олія але це не точно але це не точно
картина яка поруч із моною венедиктовою
[музика]
портретом дневіри де бабіков
це прекрасно
Друзі на портреті герой обертається
ліворуч картина сильно переписана її тло
стало набагато темнішим окремі деталі
видалені імовірно в оригінальній версії
роботи зеленській прислухається до
когось невидимого пам'ятаєте була
постійна людина яка шептала йому на
вушко Що йому робити то він мабуть
прислухається до когось А за вушком
нікого нема то він не знає що робити Але
добре що є горностаї Який його підтримує
і
зігріває зігріває все що треба
Ганс Рудольф гігер дбр3
холост та крило ліє нічні
жахіття чи впізнали Ви хто тут
зображений напишіть самі в
коментарях можна уявити яким би був шок
митця якби на його виставку вломились
спецестети дбр і заарештували геть все
що би сказав гігер що би написав яких би
поптвор намалював ми цього не дізнаємось
художник помер б'ють дбрівці Це я так
кричу що поліція прийдіть сюди поліція
тут порушення закону а поліція просто
дивиться і все це Новіков адвокат мене
чути
дякую
допит не
відбувся Бо такого плану здійснити допит
не
було
насправді спробувати
кочити Петру Порошенку повідомлення
пропідоз
Як тільки ми з колегами зайшли до
кабінету слідчого ще до того як
розпочався допит До нас прийшов
працівник офісу
генпрокурора До речі не представивши
уповноваження бо це напевно не була пані
венедиктова яка одна згідно з законо
булаважена повідомляти про підозву в
таких випадках і спробува здійснити
повідомлення оскільки це не було згідно
з Законом і це не було згідно з
процедурою
ми відмовилися спілкуватися з цією
людиною і зараз Петро Порошенко залишив
будинок дбф Я сподіваюся що відразу
зрозуміло що вся ця справа про картини
вона насправді була
фейковою вона не мала мети досягти
певного законного вирішення вони мабуть
і не сподіваються що в них получиться і
це був тільки привід щоб оголосити підоз
Сьогодні я вважаю дуже важливим щоб
всесе суспільство розуміло що
відбувається що згідно з позицією яку
вже висловив пан Зеленський президент
Зеленський офс Генерального прокурора
пані венедиктова та дбр а фактично коють
злочин вони
фактично пробують привоти до до
кримінальної відповідальності Петра
Порошенка без жодних ст
А справа про яку йдеться Це справа про
призначення пана сьомочка заступником
Голови служби зовнішньої розвідки ви
знаєте
що це звинувачення цея справа була
сформульована так що начебто Порошенко з
метою вкрасти
гроші тобто заробітну платню цьо очки
призначив його в обхід процедури на цю
посаду це абсурд
колишній Генеральний прокурор Пан Руслан
ребашанко вже говорив що це юридичний
треш і так воно є насправді це юридични
треш ми бачили що пані
венедиктовой зайняло майже
місяці щоб прийняти це рішення щоб
підписати проект ці підозри якій вона
могла підписати з першого дня коли вона
була призначена на посаду
генпрокурора
вона не мала то це зробити вона розуміє
Я Я впевнений що вона це розуміє що
підписання такої безпідставної підозри
означає перспективу реальну перспективу
для неї самей
бути виличено до кримінальної
відповідальності нам дуже залежить на
тому щоб ви стежили за цією ситуацією Я
сподіваюся що всі розуміють наскільки це
важливо Це перший за
рік це перша поважна спроба здійснення
поважного політичного тиску на опозицію
це політично переслідування Петра
Порошенка як політичного опонента
президента Зеленського як лідера
опозиції це дуже-дуже
серйозно
Ми
звичайно влаштуємо всі наповіні захди ми
напевно звернемося безпосередньо до
офісу Генерального прокурора ми
безпосередньо оскаржимо до суду кожного
таку спробу і кожну слідчу дію
спрямовану в цьому керунку А головне за
все щоб в нас залишався постійний
контакт з суспільством той факт що ви
тут присутні зараз той факт що ви
стежите за цією ситуацією це головне бо
такі речі як політичне переслідування
лідера опозиції можуть відбуватися або в
недемократичному суспільстві або в
таємниці від суспільства Я сподіваюся що
Ані того Ані другого В нас
немає слідчий не збирався починати до
слідчий просто залучив нас до свого
кабінету До речі я нагадаю як як це було
здійснено вже після того як Печерський
суд визнав незаконно обшук в музеї
Гончара вже після того як дії слідчих
було визнане не невідповідними до закону
слідчі продовжуючи цю кримінальну справу
Звернулися до Печерського суду з
клопотанням про привід про примусовий
привід Петра Порошенка на допит начебто
на допит я наголошую сьогодні 10 червня
і є певний певен нюанс нюанс полягає на
тому що згідно з новою редакцію
кримінально-процесуального кодексу
народний депутат України може бути
викликаний до нього може бути здійснено
привід виключно за результатом судового
засідання за його участю це не
надоторканість це право бути почутним це
право висловити свою думку Коли дбр
клопоче про примусовий і суддя Соколов
який виніс це рішення про привід цю
ухвалу він зробив вигляд що він не в
курсі що поте Порошенко є народним
депутатом і це це з одного боку смішно
бо в нас вже слідчі які розслідують цю
справу по картини вони як ми вже
говорили оглядали
Вікіпедію щоб з'ясувати Що Порошенко є
депутатом суддя Соколов не знає про
Вікіпедію
але зараз розуміло що це був Це була
полавка Це був трік такой трюк
і єдиною метою цього привиду І взагалі
цієї кримінальної справи Було залучити
Петра Порошенка в такі умови в кабінеті
слідчого дбр щоб до нього мог підійти
працівник офісу генпрокурора і
спробувати ще раз наголошую в порушенні
процедура прочити якийсь документ який
ві називавдовленя
продо по
справіі по справі 753 по справі так
званої справі
сьомочки це інша справа вона не має
ніякого відношення до справи про картину
[музика]
А про приліфкам Байден так званим
подякач в цій історії Він не є
самостійною фігурою Я впевнений в цьому
ні такого випадку не було І з того що ми
зараз спостерігаємо виглядає так що
генпрокурору та офіс президента їм
байдуже по якой самі справі буде підозра
хай тільки буде підозра їх влаштовує те
що це юридичний треж їх влаштовує те що
їх колишні союзники
вже просто оч їм кажу що так не можна а
сам той факт що вони підписали якусь
підозру їх
повністють будь ласка на
підставічогод на підставі того що було
прорушення процедури на повноважена
особи або ми не бачили доказів того що
це уповноважена особа це па панінедикто
якщо вона цю підозру підписала повинна
була
особисто з повним з повною
відповідальністю доручати Петру
Порошенку вона злякалася
цього На жаль і вона замість Севе
послала якогось працівника який не мав
за собою навіть завіреної копії
дорошення тому в нас були всі підстави
відмовитися від від спілкування з цим
чоловіком він сказав що це був Це була
підозра так оскільки він не уповноважена
особа сенсу сі
я вже сказав по справі смоч будь ласка
Якщо є нове
питання следующий раз поговорим про
следующий раз же Дякую
дяку зарплата
[музика]
пащо друзі зараз закінчилася акція і як
звісно
завжди треба отримувати зарплату всі
парохоботи зарплату сьогодні отримають
це саме та зарплата про яку президент
Зеленський боїться заходити в Facebook
того щоб всім порахо там платять от вони
всі тут зібрались сьогодні і їм бачите
заплатили будь ласка тобі тобі багато
зарплати
нерогощайтесь
Дякую пресу потрібно підтримувати пресу
потрібно підтримувати Так це у нас що
там це хто Це хто такий почекайте
почекайте
Почекай шановні народні Почекайте
секуі присядьте колеги присядьте Будь
ласка присядьте
[музика]
дозвольте А можете присісти будь ласка
ви
закрива в нього не буде мікрофону і ми
зараз нічого не почуємо На жаль в нього
нема мікрофону я нічого не почую не
понятно подивимось картину це на
телеканалах можна буде подивитись Так це
можна на телеканалах
подивитись це необхідності Справа в тому
що ми майже дійшли до кінця насправді
друзі в нас тут трошки зовсім залишились
хочу показати вам
квадрати якраз під цю музику можна
розгледіти тут пана бабікова адвоката
януковичаганьбаганьбадитонь ганьба
ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба
ганьба Я чесно кажучи не знаю хто це і
чому йому кричать там якийсь представник
дбр ми нічого не почуємоганьба давай
може я підіду підійду поближче я спробую
підійти ближче а чи зможе він щось
розказатиньба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба ганьба
габа ганьба ганьба ганьба ві дуже схожи
Нади Володимир
ясй молодо
ще ось
таке
і дівчинка з
персиками Ні це не ті персики про які ви
[музика]
подумали це ніж як у дбрівців був Що ж
друзі це всі картини які ми могли вам
показати більше немає Дякую за те що
дивились цей прямий ефір обов'язково
поставте лайк екскурсоводу вподобайку за
таку чудову екскурсію для вас сьогодні
вела Марія мадзігон допомагав знімати
Андрій Луганський Андрій серебрянський
Дуже дякую йому за це
обов'язково тактак йому теж поставте
вподобайку обов'язково підписуйтесь на
цей канал щоби бачити ці стріми от прям
в прямому ефірі в цей момент мати
можливість коментувати якось доповнювати
задавати питання і так далі обов'язково
Підписуйтесь ставте вподобайки поширюйте
це відео щоб більше людей насолодились
мистецтвом сучасним і поба чись па-па
[музика]
всім